[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
Це колись було село-мільйонник.
[Полтавщина,
Панасівка]
А тепер максимум тут
двадцять житлових будинків. Усе.
[Валерій Єрмаков
Художник]
І стільки ж і людей. Двадцять осіб.
Ані магазину, ані аптеки, ані медпункту.
Немає нічого тут.
До цього я жив у Полтаві самій.
Продали там квартиру.
Жінці захотілось землю обробляти.
А мені треба було творити.
Вона мені дала можливість це все робити.
Я б не сказав, що надихала,
але не заважала — це так.
Ну і взагалі-то я з нею радився завжди.
А потім вона сказала мені зробити Вакулу,
і я послухався. Це її ідея.
А я ніколи над цим не задумувався:
це має бути суттю людини –
щось робити.
Робити я почав ще у п'ять років свистунці
з глини розфарбовувати, мене мама навчила.
Горіти треба, хотіти, бажати!
Щоб був потяг до творчості.
Ох ти, це я від кішки закриваю.
Вона відкриває і залишає двері відчиненими.
Не зачиняє за собою.
Це з пінопласту.
Беру шматки, більше як бруски,
щоб були прямокутними чи квадратними, і клею.
А тоді ніж в руки.
І все, більше ніяких інструментів. Тільки ніж.
Цього мене ніхто не вчив.
По журналах [вчився].
Виписував собі видання  «Художник».
Оце моя, можна сказати, улюблена картина. Чому?
Те, що я хотів виразити в неї на обличчі —
я виразив.
Відчужений погляд.
І думаючи про те, що буде з ним.
Мені подобається краса.
Раніше в СРСР зневажливо ставились
і казали «салонний живопис».
Вона вважалась такою собі «красою».
А тепер, між іншим,
цей «салонний живопис» популярний.
Ось обличчя, наприклад.
Схожого ж нічого немає?
Але тут є усмішка.
Я прагнув зробити.
Але не таку, щоб вона була з широко
роззявленим ротом. Богині це не пристойно.
Але все ж таки щось можна було взяти в неї.
Не роззявлений рот.
Ось так я все і роблю.
Не копіюю.
Не сприйміть за розбещення,
але я виписував ось такий журнал.
[сміється]
Бог створив жінку найкрасивішим
створінням на планеті.
Мені треба ось ці відстані.
Ось ці, ось ці. І інші.
Шию і все інше.
Габарити. У мене тут немає натурниць.
Я беру із цих книг одну, іншу,
де більш видно.
Міряю і виводжу середнє.
І тоді роблю.
Добре, якби була натурниця.
Навіть руки, пальця —
і то немає, де взяти.
Мене завжди питають:
«А чого ти їх не продав?»
На виставках я бував.
На Сорочинській ярмарці.
Звісно, я знаю їм ціну.
Але не хочу їх продавати.
Душа не лежить їх продавати.
Мені здається дріб'язковим: продавати їх.
Бо я багато витрачаю на них енергії.
Душу вкладаю.
Мені треба, щоб люди бачили та захоплювалися
і знайоме щось знаходили.
Але для цього треба, як я сказав, горіти.
От я загорівся зробити скульптури і їх зроблю.
І добре зроблю.
Але наступну, якщо доживу.
То взагалі.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Дмитро Охріменко, Павло Пашко]
[Продюсерка
Наталка Панченко]
[Редакторка відео
Карина Пілюгіна]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажер
Олександр Легостаєв]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Музика
Endless Melancholy, 5 Vymir, Panivalkova]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]